welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for miss marvel introducing
kamala khan as the new mcu hero taken
directly from my high school years
another adventure shirt cute not today
mabisto i am really digging the vibes of
this series and its trailer is filled
with subtle clues for what could really
be going on here so i'm gonna break it
all down frame by frame let's go
[Music]
okay so first off i just want to say
i get it
you get what we open with kamala's diary
when she doodles this pig flying into
space as she wishes she could be among
the stars and one day will be this might
actually be her stuffed animal that we
see later on her bed coming from a
devout muslim family she's not supposed
to eat pork but as we saw in the comics
she still loves to smell bacon calling
it delicious delicious infidel meat
first introduced in the 2013 captain
marvel comics kamala khan shortly after
got her own solo series in 2014 where we
saw a terrigen mist bomb enveloped her
and caused her to envision her heroes
captain marvel iron man and captain
america and she emerged from that cocoon
emulating the appearance of her hero
carol danvers but with the powers to
embig in her limbs until she realized
she could just be herself and maintain
that stretchy ability in her own form
and appearance now pterogenesis is
actually the process by which inhumans
are formed as we saw with quake and
agents of shield but the mcu version of
kamala khan might be going in a
different direction more on that later
also you'll notice among our doodles is
ant-man versus man ant with scott lang
having some fleshy human limbs on that
segmented body sexiest ant alive there's
also a note for driving lesson today an
essay due on the 19th scratch that the
16th uh oh and a reminder to include
references and quotes and a drawing of
herself calling this all boring i also
like the little glimpse of kamala's
fashion with her index finger now
painted a different color then we move
past a world history textbook showing
ancient egypt on the cover a corner of
the world that will be explored even
sooner on moon night and then we glide
into kamala's fantasy escapism in the
form of her drawings the marvel studios
title card within her comic book
sketched out thought bubble and then the
frame itself condenses into a hand-drawn
version of that depicting how kamala
sees her whole world through the filter
of her own imagination now covering
footage with animated sound effect words
action lines word bubbles which you'll
know to spill out from beyond that frame
is the kind of aesthetic that we saw in
scott pilgrim vs the world and
spider-man into the spider-verse and now
to see it in the mcu like this is a
really vibrant choice that not only
takes us inside kamala's mind but hints
at the way her physical powers are
actually manifested from her wish
fulfillment like wanda maximoff her
inner world becomes everyone else's
physical reality now kamala's guidance
counselor is mr wilson his name is
likely a nod to g willow wilson who
wrote these miss marvel comics and is
also referenced in that desk divider
being labeled gw now if you grew up
collecting pokemon or magic the
gathering cards and wants something to
scratch that competitive collecting itch
raid shadow legends has over 600 champs
waiting at you ready to collect and do
battle use the links below to download
raid to your mobile phone or your pc to
honor the great character design on raid
i have assembled my top 5 favorite
beards in raid and number five i got sir
nicholas who looks like santa claus but
just slightly more jacks and well
groomed also in the sacred order i like
phoenix and his well-defined beard he's
like pirate j guylin hall and the orcs
faction old hermit jorg is a really epic
beard in the skinwalkers faction i like
the wildness of koronharz mean that's a
beard and a champion you don't want to
mess with but the top spot's got to go
to fellow skinwalker longbeard he
delivers on his name he is a beard and
it's long he's also a great legendary
champion this is the best time to get
started in raid and if you click my link
in the description or scan my qr code
here on screen you'll get a free starter
pack worth almost thirty dollars and
we're talking a free epic champion tay
rail 200 000 silver one energy refill
one xp boost and one ancient shard so
that you can summon awesome champions as
soon as you get in game all of this
treasure will be waiting for you right
here his office is filled with
motivational posters like that classic
hang in there kitty and then on the door
you can totally do this he's also got
tissues on his desk for students who
come in crying or leave crying these as
we saw on no way home getting into the
right college couldn't be a pretty
stressful thing now this might just be
me but the way kamala writes her
lowercase gs in her word bubbles it's
just interesting circles connected by a
straight line i don't know i've never
seen g's written this way but i also
don't know how those gen zeros are doing
it these days but to me this at least
looks like the middle portion of the pym
tech logo circles connected by lines
could just be another example of how
kamala is really an ant-man as we saw in
her diary and specifically ant-man's pym
tech enabled ability to embiggen moving
on
high school
kamala kamala another adventure shirt
cute she thinks i'm some kind of weirdo
you are a weirdo
boys excuse me yeah
you're kind of on my shirt sorry okay we
get this really cool shot of the clock
rotating counterclockwise as we anchor
on the minute hand flying through the
day much like peter parker in the
opening sequence of spider-man
homecoming kamala khan just spent her
whole school day staring at the clock
waiting for it to end behind her is a
poster reading vote dusted for prez he's
a very good choice dustin berry was
actually the set decorator set buyer for
this series along with ant-man and
another ant-man story movie civil war
but look at you you made yourself vince
you can and dustin berry you go dustin
berry the girl zoe zimmer deliberately
mispronounces kamala and disses her
shirt zoe is actually from the miss
marvel comics popular girl whom kamala
ends up saving from the hudson river and
the two become really good friends
especially with zoe even developing a
crush on kamala's turkish-american
friend nakia baadir seen here alongside
bruno corelli now kamala's avengers
shirt reads ladies let's get
informational mesha and all with captain
marvel and wasp and valkyrie all wearing
glasses of course a play on olivia
newton john's let's get physical i
assume inspired by these women and all
the others leading that final charge in
endgame and yeah evangeline lilly based
on your recent comments let's definitely
get informational please come on let's
see zoey with devil horns and i just
gotta say between this and the devil
horns in no way home at this point it
honestly feels like marvel studios is
just mephisto trolling me to which i
would say he sees you he sees all in the
circle q store kamala and bruno stand
beside this captain marvel cosplay
outfit with a looks like a paper mache
mask i think kamala made this now bruno
actually works at this location in the
comics kamala uses it as her unofficial
headquarters then at a party kamala does
some true scott pilgrim ogling at
cameron who looks like he just hopped
out of that pool despite everyone else
wearing outerwear maybe the guy got
pushed in or jumped in on a dare or just
thirst trapping all these girls in the
comics cameron was actually hit with
that same terrigen mist that gave kamala
her powers causing cameron to develop an
ability where he emits a bluish energy
from his body and then channels
electrical energy into objects that
caused him to glow and explode he was
later recruited by the villain lineage
framing him here with that blue tinted
steam over the pool could be a nod to
his terrigen missed origins and his
powers nakia has tied her headscarf into
this beautiful bun and as they stare at
cameron notice poor bruno off to the
side clearly feeling inadequate no one
talks about bruno no no no don't worry
kid you got a bright future ahead of you
making youtube videos for some
lin-manuel tracks to make the viewers
cringe also why am i advising a
fictional character next clip
what you're staring at the window in
your little fantasy land
[Applause]
kamala hey already really come on like
do i have to figure out my whole future
before launchers
okay we get this great euphoria style
shot swooping in on kamala with the
classroom projector light beaming around
her right as we hear the weeknd's
blinding lights her head is totally
casting a shadow on that screen by the
way this is actually the same kind of
lighting and framing used in one
division to introduce that skrull who
introduced monica rambo in the movie
theater projector light and i do think
we will see some scrolls appear in this
miss marvel series to set up the secret
invasion series then the frame cuts back
into that hand-drawn inner frame of
kamala's imagination showing her
fantasies suited up in the captain
marvel outfit but the one from the
beginning of end game the red on top not
the blue topped one that carol changed
into in the final battle and wore in
that shang chief post-credits scene so
this fantasy is specifically the captain
marvel who saved iron man and she
strikes a classic black widow superhero
pose nice another fantasy shows her
suited up but wearing tiara and carrying
roses like the homecoming queen and then
a shot of cameron on his car with roses
flower petals raining down from nowhere
this is like kamala's american beauty
fantasy and i feel just as uncomfortable
looking at it let's move on maybe
they're right
i spend too much time
and fantasyland
that is not to you
okay kamala and bruno sit on the roof of
this building that neon sign from the
other side actually reads madison that
first letter is an m there but beneath
their feet is a poster or a painting
that i think reads iron man there so
like peter parker's world she's just
surrounded by iconography of iron man
and reminders how he's dead and again
with the steam there's just lots of mist
in this trailer for a story that
seemingly won't use terrigen mist to
give kamala khan her powers who knows
tarajin miss may be behind all of this
we see some shots of kamala and her
family praying at their mosque and then
kamala and bruno at this display of a
sparkly captain marvel costume the signs
in her badge necklace read new jersey
avengers looks like some kind of expo or
convention which might be like that a
day celebration in the avengers game
that kamala attends in san francisco
where a terrorist attack overloads a
terrigen energy crystal powering that
helicarrier that ends up releasing a
mist that ends up giving kamala her
powers you'll notice kamala also wears a
captain marvel patch on her jacket the
later shot of her on her bike shows this
is a green canvas jacket much like carol
danvers flight suit and it even has that
same air force test pilot patch on the
sleeve kamala's mother minivacon
criticizes her costume that may lead
kamala to define her parents to attend
that convention to show off her cosplay
really how she gets in all that trouble
moving on it's not really the brown
girls from jersey city who saved the
world
that's a fantasy too
okay interesting shots here of kamala
snooping around an attic with a
flashlight where she finds his chest
filled with files and in which she finds
these bracelets these glow when kamala
snaps them on and you'll notice they
have this star burst icon on the cuff
similar to the astral iconography of the
cree that captain marvel emulates as her
logo now in the reaction i wondered if
these could be the nega bands from the
captain marvel comics given to captain
marvel by the creased supreme
intelligence that ends up really
trapping captain marvel in the negative
zone should be a really cool way to
bring in the fantastic four potentially
into the mcu but based on the powers
they give kamala khan they could also be
quasars quantum bands which have similar
energy projection powers i'll just say
that the design on the cuffs suggests
that these come from some kind of alien
race extraterrestrial origin personally
i'm getting more cree vibes we don't
know whose attic this is or why kamala
came up here but nearby are some lab
coats and some lab equipment and a few
dollhouse miniatures one could see more
parallels with hank pym who has a
history of shrinking down buildings to
miniature size or even with howard stark
who had a miniature stark expo in his
home but my theory is that this attic
could belong to someone in kamala's
community who might be revealed as a
scroll in hiding remember the skrull
talos posing as nick fury and spider-man
far from home hinted at a skrull cree
shadow war currently being waged i
thought cree having sleeper cells was
top secret information these bracelets
could have been creed weapons of mass
destruction stolen and hidden by a
skrull on earth and then accidentally
discovered by kamala thinking they were
just cool additions to her cosplay but
then they accidentally power her up into
a creed powered superhero like her hero
captain marvel which would be what draws
kamala into the cree squirrel conflict
that monica rambo is now joining the
squirrel faction of based off that one
division post-credits scene which would
explain how all these three come
together in the marvels next year just
my theory there little mcu detail there
i love when kamala first powers up and
her eyes glow purple pink right behind
her is a statue of rocket raccoon from
that avengers expo just a little clue
pointing to despite this being an
earthbound story we are dealing with
truly cosmic implications here and when
she falls backwards she passes some
other cosplayers you can see an iron man
two different captain america shields
and then the november footage actually
showed a nebula here then she falls
through the floor into a kind of sunken
place it looks like but she ends up
right side up surrounded by a new crowd
of figures who are these people are they
just a mere reflection of the cosplayers
or are they someone else remember cree
technology is neurally infused the
supreme intelligence takes a different
form to whomever sees it and carol
danvers infusion through the cree tahiti
process left her with false memories so
if these bracelets these cuffs are cree
tech kamala in this moment could be
mentally projected into the memories of
the cree warrior who last wore these
these others in this purpley realm could
be past cree on the planet hala and then
kamala could come out of that state with
those kree powers manifesting her own
inner desires the way the cree's supreme
intelligence in a way reflects something
you deeply desire and of course these
vibrant colors and energy waves
definitely match the visuals we saw for
carol danvers power up and monica rambo
passing through that radiation wall of
westview to become boton all three women
empowered with the same kind of cosmic
radiation onto the next clip
did something happen to you no why did
you hear something come on
what does it feel like
cosmic
okay kamala sitting at the table
envisioned some light pouring into her
home through a kind of portal and more
mist i'm not sure if this is literal
terrigen missed or just missed in her
mind but missed her brother amir and her
father yusuf check in on her her room is
actually filled with captain marvel
posters by the door more art of that pig
now a unicorn actually over kamala's bed
is a poster of captain marvel showing a
specific comic this is jerry dodson's
cover of earth's mightiest hero number
five then we see the circle q shop
exploding oh no and then kamala looks at
her glowing hands and this place with
green walls and weapons in a case i
think this actually might be part of a
trip kamala takes to visit relatives in
pakistan which would be where she meets
the vigilante red dagger kareem all part
of a process perhaps to train kamala to
be more of a hero kamala says her powers
feel cosmic another indicator that
they're coming from the same cosmic
radiation source as monica rambo and
carol danvers powers and we see what
those look like she projects these discs
of energy that she uses to close doors
and then lily pad through the air now
again in the comics she's supposed to be
able to stretch or embig in her limbs
but actually if you look closely at her
last jump here her arms and legs are
totally stretching this isn't like a
green lantern energy covering her limbs
it's inside of her stretching her body
out moving on
[Music]
i always thought i wanted this kind of
life
but i never imagined any of this
do you know what you are
okay the trailer only hints at this
shady group of people in black suvs i'm
wondering if they could be part of some
enforcement agency like the dodc but in
this case maybe an agency tracking down
scrolls or inhumans throughout society
we see another misty shot and an alley
with these four mystery figures there's
a woman a man another woman and another
man now i wonder if this group could
actually be those cree sleeper cell
agents coming back to reclaim the cuffs
or maybe some squirrel agents coming to
recruit her but actually you can see
that woman on the far left appearing in
the background behind kamala in the
wedding venue so this group is going to
be an ongoing threat that goes after the
khan family one that she has to take on
in the middle of a relative's wedding
and then more shashowing kamala's visit
to pakistan a procession of people
passed a large fire and the kamala
enters that green building that we saw
earlier following this woman who later
asks if she knows what she is this woman
according closed captioning is named
najma that could be the older relative
who shelters kareem and knows more about
those cuffs squirrel and then kamala and
the vigilante red dagger kareem fight or
maybe just spar in this pakistani train
station notice the urdu on the sign
there her giant fist smashes into that
drink stand and then cut into a
different scene where kamala retracts
the giant fist this is at the wedding
where right after this we can see her
dancing alongside bruno bruno moving in
bruno playing a pretty big role here
helping a wounded cameron down the
subway car as they both flee men in dark
suits you can barely see in the car
behind so cameron will also play a
bigger role in this plot and simply
being the hunky boy kamala is into he
could be a new human like he becomes the
comics or maybe a skrull or a fellow
inhuman that kamala must protect from
that enforcement agency then a quick
shot of a car getting blown off the
ground by a colorful shockwave released
by kamala as she smashes another car and
again you can see her limbs stretched
she is totally going to be a
shapeshifter in this series armored
soldiers charge down a school hallway
and then kamala forms a shield to
protect cameron from gunfire in the
background are some school buses
suggesting this is going down outside
that school it's just so scary to see
that shield breaking apart from some of
the bullets showing how kamala is not
yet mastering her powers she still is in
a lot of danger all right onto the final
clip
[Music]
okay after the title our final shot
shows kamala sitting on that street
light looking out at manhattan perfectly
recreating of the cover of miss marvel
number five but i just love how this
compares to that earlier shot of her
with her bike staring out of the city
with a sense of longing to be part of
something bigger but now even after
becoming a true superhero she doesn't
leave jersey city for manhattan she
stays this is still her home she's just
looking at the city from a higher
vantage point like more of a guardian
protecting her turf from any threats
from the big bad city or from beyond
folks i am super excited for this series
and of course new rockstars is
definitely going to be covering it when
it drops on june 8th so be sure to
subscribe to new rockstars for all of
our marvel content you can follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea boss you can
follow me rockstars of course thank you
so much for watching and bye-bye
[Music]
you